Mình mấy tăng chính, tà mua sẽ đà được sôn. Cô vấn án ninh của xa hàng quân vừa rủ lóc cho biết,
Mỹ và hàng quốc đã đạt đồng thận rằng một tiêu phía nhìn thoá bán nào chủ tiên là nguyên tác không thể đạo hợp.
Hàn quốc cũng nhìn mạnh lộ trình bác sẽ đoạn đồng băng thất giảm và lỗi bỏ hoàn toàn trương trình hạp nhất tên lừa.
Là con đường thục tế nhất, để đạt một tiêu lâu dài, sôn cũng khẳng định đệ nối lại đối thoại giá miền chủ tiên là phên chốt.
Bởi chỉ thông qua xây dẫn lòng tin, tâm ớt giảm cần thẳng mơ của thế giới chỉ bình vấn.
Chính phó hàn quốc xin thời gian qua cũng đã trình khai một số biển phát,
nhằm giảm áp lực đối đầu, xong thường nhận tiến trình và lối sẹn dù trường ai.
Chuy đó, đi tổng tống hàn quốc li trên miang tương tuy mố, kế hoạc phi nhà nhân hoa sẽ được thúc đại trên nền tặng li mình chạp chảy với Mỹ,
và tất cả nước lực ngoại giá chủ đạo với bình dưỡng.
Chuy tiên cũng đã xa tiên bố khẳng định không thể đổi lập trường và bảo khả nâng đối thoại về hành quốc hay Mỹ.